- You're going to do
everything in your power
to get there, you feel me.
It's that grind, it's that hunger
to getting to your goal
My main thing is always being myself
No sleep, no days off.
It's just so much hard work.
(crowd cheering)
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
actor and rapper, Joey Bada$$,
and my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
You might win a prize as well,
and also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- My advice to the people
is to follow your heart.
You know, eff what anybody
is saying to you about
a dream or an idea that you have.
If you really feel like a feeling and
you know what I'm talking about like that,
the gut, that deep feeling,
- [Interviewer] That
right, like I can do this.
- I should do this or I can do this.
Just do it,'cause we
only got one life to live
and honestly that might
be the test of your life.
That might be the test of this journey.
Everybody has the chance to jump.
The choice to jump and you know sometimes
you got to make that jump
(woman laughs)
I encourage everyone to make the jump,
you know what I'm saying, 'cause
you don't want to live your life
thinking like damn, I should've
jumped back 20 years ago.
10 years ago,
- [Interviewer] Life could've
been different and everything.
- Could've been, would've been different,
but the thing is you will never know
'cause you never took it,
never took it so take the risk.
I want to put people in
the mind state that I have
because I think that it's
a real healthy one to keep,
you feel me.
I think it's real beneficent.
- You said the mind state that I have,
what is that mind state?
- I'mma explain, it's
real beneficial I think
to you know just society
period to mankind,
and like with this current
album, you feel me,
with the message that I'm
currently trying to push
the concept of this whole
picture is basically
I'm welcoming people to this
before the money mind state.
And what that really is, is like
that before the money mind state
is that time where you
at, before you realize
all right, you know you got this goal.
You got these things that you want to do,
and it's that moment
where you realize that
you're going to do
everything in your power
to get there, you feel me.
It's that grind, it's that hunger
to getting to your goal
and even once you get there
it's all about keeping that mind state,
like even me right now I feel like
I attained so much, I've came so far,
but I'm still in that
before the money mind state.
Like I still got that same grind as if
I was just like still rapping in school
and (censored) like that, you feel me.
And I want people to apply that to life
no matter what their goals are,
if they want to be a
doctor and (censored),
I want them to be in that before the money
mind state of it.
Like yo,
- A genuine passion,
that genuine love.
- yeah, that genuine passion.
Yeah, and I just want people
to always relive that,
and live with that everyday.
- I've also seen comparisons to
to Nas Illmatic, you know what I'm saying.
What type of pressure does
that put on you, if any?
- [DJ] Or maybe inspiration.
- Or inspiration?
- If anything, it drives me
to not sound like that.
- Okay.
- [Joey] You know.
- Yeah.
- It drives me to be myself because
you know, the comparisons are great,
they're always great and
it's a honor to be compared
to somebody like Nas and
Illmatic, you feel me,
'cause that's a great,
immense body of work,
but my main thing is always being myself
and sounding like myself.
I don't want to sound like anyone.
I want people to be like,
yo, you sound like Joey.
We became the change
that we wanted to see,
slowly, that's what we started growing to,
and progressing towards.
When I basically grew up and I got older,
you know, even when you see movies
as a child, and you grow
up and you watch it again,
you understand it differently,
you see different things about it.
That was pretty much the
same case with music for me.
When I got older and then
I revisited these things
and everything, it hit me
like an epiphany again,
and everything and I identify that as
what rap really is, you know,
that's traditional rap for me.
And basically when I started making 1999
when we formed pro era in 2011/2012,
what we realized in the game,
what we loved about Hip Hop so much
we didn't see in the game, so
we basically decided to become
the change we wanted to see.
- What's your success?
What's your secret?
- I mean, you know the game changed,
soon as the internet came around.
With the internet I
know what it did for me,
it cut out the middle man.
I didn't have to go out physically
and meet somebody, a A&R from a label
or some (censored), my A&R was YouTube.
- [DJ] Yeah.
- Me putting my videos up,
you know what I'm saying,
and sending it to World Star
and hoping it get picked up,
which it eventually did
way after the (censored).
You know, the fans are who
got me traveling overseas,
you know what I'm saying, the fans
who got me playing on the
TV, playing on the radio.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think it's
extremely important,
it's extremely imperative to give back
to those people and make sure that
they're happy, not just content
but they're elated (laughs)
from what you're giving them.
- Yeah.
- And also these people are inspired by me
so I just do the best that I can
to keep uplifting them and to show them
yo, they're just like me and same way
I follow my dreams, why can't you too.
- How difficult has the journey been
in the four years that
people don't get to see?
- There's a lot of late nights,
early mornings, you know,
there's a lot of little sleep.
I shouldn't even say it's a lot of that,
it's like absolutely
no sleep, no days off.
It's just so much hard work.
It's never really,
especially for a guy like me,
like I'm such a hard worker, I don't
I'm one of those people that
don't know how to relax.
I don't know how to chill out you know.
Even if I'm on a vacation,
I'm still trying to find a way to work.
I already know the energy and the passion
and just the truth that
I put into my music.
So it's like I don't need
people to validate that for me.
You know what I mean, so and that
comes from me being at a level where
I just want to be content
with everything I do.
So if I already know what
I'm putting into my work,
I don't need to be wrapped up about
what I'm finna get out
or get back from it.
It's like, you know what I mean,
I'm just here to do this,
you know what I mean.
And yeah that's what it is,
it's like don't worry to be,
there's a quote, I can't
remember who said it but,
it's basically like, "don't
strive for recognition,
"just be worthy of it" you know
what I mean, it's something
along those lines.
- I love that.
- But yeah.
- Yeah, you can't live your
life waiting for validation
from people, 'cause
you'll always be miserable
at that point.
You know what I mean?
- Exactly.
- It's just it's never (laughs)
- It's like my happiness is determined,
- Based on you?
- Yeah, it's outside of me.
- That's crazy, yeah.
- And it should never be that way.
I think they are, I think you know,
it's a interesting thing to watch me grow,
you know what I'm saying.
I tend to look at myself from
a outside perspective a lot.
You know, and I just
try to be my role model.
- That's how you do it.
- I try to be
a cat that I could follow
if I wasn't myself.
(rapping)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because KA asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description,
and you can go and cast your vote.
I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video,
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow,
leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Hideo Yoneyama,
thank you so much Hideo for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that post,
and putting it on Twitter,
I really appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoy the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- When I'm doing something,
I do it to the fullest
capacity, the fullest potential,
I want to be one of the
greatest artists of all time
I don't just rap to be
an underground rapper,
I rap because I want to
be one of the biggest,
one of the greatest ever,
one of the greatest
influences in the world
when it comes to music,
you know what I'm sayin?
That's my mission, that's my goal.
I always love when I challenge myself
to make something different,
that's always something
that makes me happy,
and makes me proud of my work,
cause anytime I approach the mic
I'm trying to create a new sound,
I ain't ever tryin to
re-make what I already did,
you know what I'm sayin?
So, yeah,
- I love that
- I feel like the
challenges for young artists
probably comes more when you're like,
"alright, I need to go
beyond throwing down a 16,
"I need to put together
a complete record."
- I don't find it too challenging,
because, you know as an artist
it's something that we do.
The thing with me, I
don't just keep it basic,
like I won't just have a
normal structured song,
like you know a verse, hook, verse, hook,
like you know,
I might just have a long ass verse,
and then a hook at the end,
there's no rules.